Kendall and Kylie just announced their  new video game app today and at just 18  years old  Kylie herself is worth they reported and  million bucks what would you say is the  biggest and piece of advice or lesson  you receive from your mom about the  business be nice to everybody and just  behave well and she kind of just taught  us to be like great let's do something I  guess  clearly Kylie's taking the advice her  latest business venture is a new line of  nail polish for sinful colors I always  change my nails for my mood so I wanted  to give like a huge diversity of colors  especially and as if she couldn't get  any busier Kylie hinted we might be  seeing a lot more of her soon but you  never do a spinoff  like with one of your sisters maybe  Kendall or I was thinking about it yeah  I was talking with one of my sisters  about it but I guess we'll just have to  wait and see